hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my first Voltron video if you guys
didn't know Voltron legendary defender
is the new series from The Legend of
Korra people is basically them doing
Voltron this will just be for the first
couple of episodes they really introduce
you to the world what's going on and
what's changed from the original series
depending on which version of Voltron
you've watched before even if you've
never watched Voltron before you don't
remember it from the 80s the first
episode does a really good job of
introducing you to the universe the
animation studio the producers the
writers all people from Legend of Korra
so you'll recognize the look and feel
this a little bit
it has a very Korra like energy to it
there are a couple nice twists that you
don't learn about till later in this
series but I'll talk about that when I
get to spoilers but if you have seen
some of the original Voltron you'll
recognize a lot of familiar story
elements some of the characters they've
tweaked a few things the pilot in the
color scheme have changed just a little
bit so Shiro pilots the black line he's
kind of like the captain in the original
series that was Keith Lantz who's the
blue pilot in the original series was
the red pilot so they changed a few
minor things really they substituted
Shiro for Sven so I think that choice
was made just to bring it closer to its
Asian roots because this is one of those
series that's like transformers or Power
Rangers Japanese series repurposed for
American audiences so for those of you
that didn't watch cartoons in the 80s or
the early 90s a lot of times what TV
networks would do is they would take a
Japanese series that was really popular
and they would cut it up and use like
the big you know mecha anime battle
scenes like the really heavily animated
scenes and then just add a little bit of
new footage to change story elements and
then aired on American television that's
what they did with Power Rangers that's
what they did with Voltron that's what
they did with transformers so a lot of
the story elements from this first
episode like the coming together of the
Lions Shiro escaping from kings archons
fighting pits is a lot like the first
couple of episodes of the original
Voltron so there are a couple ongoing
storylines the biggest being King Zarkon
trying to get his hands on the Lions
they've explained that the Lions have
basically been dormant for about ten
thousand years
the back story they tease the mythology
behind Princess Allura is people is very
similar to the original series there was
a great battle Hagar and King Zarkon
were able to defeat their people so in
an attempt to preserve the future they
divided the lions and spread them out
across
the universe so that they would remain
hidden so the new pilots have this quasi
spiritual bond with the Lions themselves
there were supernatural aspects to the
original series like Princess Allura 's
father appears to her as a ghost in this
he's more of a ghost in the machine of
the computer so they don't fully explain
it in the first couple of episodes
they're just going to tease that out of
the rest of the series but it's a nice
balance of Technology and spiritualism
that you saw in Legend of Korra and they
kind of treat it the same way only it's
more like lion bending the voice actors
you probably recognized at least a
couple of the voice actors Steven Yeun
from Walking Dead is playing Keith
Beck's is playing pitch and you might
think that it's weird that they picked a
girl to play a boy but there's a big
twist that you find out about later I
don't want to spoil it now but a lot of
you who watch the original series
remember that there was like a pink
outfit that the princess war she piloted
one of the Lions there's a nice twist to
that with pidge's character in this that
they explain later episodes the person
who's doing the voice for Elora is also
malachite on Steven universe she has a
pretty recognizable voice and like I
said pretty much everybody that worked
on Legend of Korra and Last Airbender
came on to this series with the
exception of Bryan and Mike so it's
basically the Korra version of Voltron
which is like the best possible thing
that could happen that's why it looks so
awesome but I feel like they really
cleaned up a lot of the classic stories
so they're not retelling the original
Voltron stories they're taking a lot of
elements and a lot of familiar things in
making them would all call better
because when you watch the original
Voltron there's a lot of really fun
things but the stories aren't that great
like I said the original companies that
made the Voltron series we're basically
just repurposing Japanese footage so
most of those Japanese cartoons that
were aired in America during the 80s
were just rampant cash grabs by toy
companies so the stories of the episodes
are actually pretty decent and I like
the weight you know because it's 13
episodes all dropped at once it's a lot
more serialized so they introduced the
idea of Shiro not really understanding
how he escaped from King Zarkon not
remembering that he was a gladiator in
his arena the secrets that Pidge is
hiding in his search for his family and
then sort of the mythology of Princess
Allura is people some of the mysteries
of the castle in the more supernatural
aspects of like how they interface with
the technology how Voltron is formed the
way I understand it right now when
they're forming Voltron they formed this
mental bond
it's a lot like odo and the changelings
on Deep Space nine if you never watched
Star Trek Deep Space nine it's one of
the best Star Trek series of all time
but in their natural state the change
legs exist in what they call the great
link where they just all kind of become
one organism that's kind of what happens
when they're forming Voltron so the
first couple of episodes is them slowly
realizing that and figuring out how to
do it but they say when they were making
it they also had some fun dealing with
the scale and the scope of Voltron
itself because it's kind of like a
combiner because when you watch
transformers you see Optimus Prime he's
already the size of a full-size truck
he's already enormous but then you have
combiners which dwarfed the scale of a
transformer so the physics behind the
lines is really interesting because
they're already enormous and when they
combine it's just crazy big but this
image will give you a really good idea
for the scale so let me know in the
comments what do you guys think about
the first couple of episodes I know
everyone's sad that Legend of Korra went
away but I think it's so awesome that
they picked a series like this to do
like the Korra team they said that when
DreamWorks bought the rights to Voltron
and they were going to redo it they came
to them while they were still working on
the last couple of episodes of Legend of
Korra
so during Korra book for like that was
slowly coming to a close DreamWorks
called him up and was like hey you know
we have the rights to Voltron we want
you guys to work on it so they locked
down a lot of the core production people
and studio Mir which is the animation
studio which is like a separate company
Studio Mir itself is supposed to be
animating for new DreamWorks Netflix
projects but I don't know what the other
is going to be Voltron I think is just
the first one and they did say that they
would be working on a season two they
have ideas for where the story is going
to go but it hasn't been confirmed yet
only that they will do more Voltron just
because Netflix is really big about
producing new content so thank god this
is not Nickelodeon behind this because
we get like 13 episodes and then we
never see it again
but what's going to happen next is I
have a Marvel spider-man video that I'm
going to post so be sure to subscribe to
get that let me know if you want me to
do more Voltron videos and I will I'll
probably make it a Saturday thing so
I'll at least do one more video for like
all the rest of the episodes so be sure
to watch it cry a little bit about
Legend of Korra
while you guys wait for me to post that
next video you can click here for my
Lady Stoneheart Game of Thrones theory
and you can click here for my Warcraft
Easter egg video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
protector of the innocent and our only
hope to save the universe